be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books so as we continue
my series on comic book concepts what I
want to do here is dip my toe in the
waters of a discussion on how to kill
the x-men with focus on Cyclops Banshee
beast Bishop Cable Iceman storm and
Kitty Pryde so in the history of Marvel
Comics the x-men have died in a
multitude of different ways and Days of
Future past the Sentinels over ran the
earth and killed off the x-men and the
world heroes in a war of attrition
during old man Logan Wolverine was
tricked into killing all the x-men and
momma had a really cool what-if story
where Jean Grey under the influence of
the Phoenix force annihilated the
entirety of the universe while these are
only a handful of instances on the whole
most stories detailing the x-men's
destruction were either part of a larger
story or saw the team destroyed all at
one time using overwhelming odds and so
the question becomes this if you were to
engineer a situation that saw the
various x-men being killed who would go
about the best chance of defeating and
eventually killing each member of the
team now in truth the answer to this
comes in a couple of different forms in
the 1990s Marvel launched a series
called the onslaught saga detailing a
scenario where Xavier is frustration
with humanity merged with Magneto's
hatred of humanity onslaught cut a
literal sloth through the superhero
community eventually requiring the
combined forces of the Avengers the
Fantastic Four the x-men x-factor
x-force and apocalypse to defeat him
with a crippling blow came with the
Incredible Hulk the defeat of onslaught
allowed for Marvel to relaunch the
Avengers in the Fantastic Four as part
of the heroes reborn universe however
within the x-men community and it's
fallout from the event Charles Xavier
initiated a set of protocols detailing
how to defeat and kill each x-man as
well as which Weavin among them was best
suited for the task while the protocols
themselves were largely isolated to the
core members of the team some of whom
we'll talk about in this video and some
of whom will talk about in others
assuming this video is popular enough
and truth
the entire concept could be extended to
the larger mutant superhero community as
a whole that being said and beginning
with Cyclops as an
a level mutant and because his eyes are
portals to a dimension that allow that
dimensions energy to pass through and
because he had suffered a head injury as
a child which activated these powers
cyclases abilities are not something he
believes he can control as a result it
would be pointless and fatal for a
mutant to attack him head-on at the same
time Cyclops is also the best trained
member of the team in hand-to-hand
combat
safer Wolverine meaning he could easily
hold his own in a straight-up fight to
this in the only way to actually defeat
and kill Cyclops is to confront him with
a being who cannot be touched in any
form or fashion meaning that ideally
Kitty Pryde and a phasing ability to
transport Cyclops to the inside of a
rock or some solid object leaving him
for dead transitioning to Banshee as a
beta level mutant and because he
possesses a sonic screen the training
he's received over his life as well as
part of the x-men have allowed him to
use his sonic scream for the purpose of
creating a sonic shield around himself
using echolocation to see objects or
people invisible to the naked eye as
well as fly and destroy solid matter
this combined with his creativity make
Banshee a reasonably credible threat
despite not being the most powerful
mutant in existence as a result the best
tactic for defeating and killing Banshee
comes in the form of Wolverine due to
his training as a ninja during his time
with a mystical Japanese organization
the hand which would allow him to
approach Banshee without detection using
his adamantium claws to kill him picking
up with Beast as a beta level mutant and
because of his enhanced strength a close
quarters battle is utter suicide and
that with the exception of a being of
equal strength beast could easily
overpower his foe however even a foe of
greater strength could also be toppled
due to beasts genius-level intelligence
allowing him to construct devices they
would provide him with an edge as a
result the best way to defeat and kill
these is to use a wide-angle distance
attack which can be achieved by
cyclopses optic beams control through
his optic visor cyclopses beams could
immerse beasts in a field of energy
incinerating him entirely despite his
agility and strength now moving on to
Bishop as an alpha level mutant with the
power to absorb all forms of energy of
unlimited levels and reach handle those
energies bishops mutant powers are his
own worst
and that much like a cup of water if too
much liquid is poured inside the couple
overflow likewise while Bishop can
absorb energy he must also continually
discharge that energy if too much is
stored inside of him it'll overpower his
body and he will literally explode
however because Bishop also hails from a
future similar to the Days of Future
past his time as part of that futures
Police Force provided him with both
tactical military training and advanced
weaponry capable of hitting on a
multitude of forces at once as a result
the best means of defeating and killing
Bishop is not just through overpowering
odds but through a form of sustained
firepower with overwhelming odds which
will overpower his energy absorption
capability and kill him now regarding
cable as a mutant with the power of
telekinesis and telepathy the process of
killing cable is actually not wildly
interesting because his infection with
the techno-organic virus threatened to
transform his cells in the machinery
emphasis was placed on training his
telekinesis to keep the virus from
consuming his body allowing very little
focus on telepathy as a result a
telepath a sufficient training and skill
could enter the mind of cable shut down
his ability to utilize telekinesis
allowing the techno-organic virus to
spread throughout his body killing him
in the process as a result the best
person suited for this would be someone
like Charles Xavier Jean Grey Rachel
summers are somewhat of equal or higher
power now moving on to Iceman despite
being an omega-level mutant body drink
requires moisture in the atmosphere for
his powers to function as a result these
capable of producing extreme heat of a
level equivalent to Bobby Drake could
force him to revert back to his human
form allowing for his death the problem
with this is that because Bobby Drake's
powers exist on a planetary level the
only earthly being capable of matching
his powers is Johnny Storm who would set
the Earth's atmosphere on fire and
annihilate the planet in its entirety
now transitioning to storm as a
potentially omega-level mutant with a
power to control the elements killing
storm is wildly difficult using her
abilities to control the elements and
being a master hand-to-hand combatant
neither ranged attacks nor close
quarters will allow for storms defeat
and death instead much like Cyclops an
enemy who can make themselves intangible
stands the only chance of real success
in addition to this because
storm served as a surrogate mother kitty
pryde the relationship between the two
presents the best opportunity for storm
to let her guard down Island Kitty Pryde
to faze herself into the body of storm
mortally wounding her or else facing
storm into a solid object after which
storm would simply just die now finally
with Kitty Pryde operating as an alpha
level mutant because she possesses the
ability to face through solid matter
this power is compounded by the fact
that she's demonstrated the ability to
achieve this feat for months at a time
because these feeds make her impervious
to physical harm the only known means of
defeating Kitty Pryde comes in the form
of telepathy
however because she's received training
in blocking telepathic probes only
beings of sufficient telepathic power
capable of breaking those blocks will
succeed meaning that psylocke DayTripper
Phoenix or Jean Grey can destroy those
blocks after which Kitty Pryde will
revert back to her normal form and could
be killed by almost any number of
conventional means what having said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and I know this is actually going to
spark some debate so I'm curious if you
guys think that these mutants can be
killed in ways other than what I've
listed that do not involve sentinels or
any other particular form has already
been done in comics then post it down
below I'm kind of curious and I'll catch
you guys later please